[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Patrice joli
pour une mise au point au sujet d'un
vote merci Madame le Présidente il
s'agit du fond de concernant le projet
de loi relatif à l'accélération des
process des procédures liés aux
nouvelles installations nucléaires je
voudrais que ce qui était considéré
comme une non participation vote soit
aujourd'hui enfin maintenant prise en
compte comme une abstention merci
la parole est à Madame Jacqueline stage
brignot également pour une mise au point
au sujet d'un vote merci madame la
Présidente effectivement sur le scrutin
public numéro 110 mes collègues
Catherine bernetti Gilbert Favreau
Sylvie gouachevant viviette Lopez
Viviane Mallet Alain million albéric de
Montgolfier Philippe pèse mec
souhaiterait voter pour madame la
Présidente si chers collègues
a été donné de ses mises au point elles
seront publiées au Journal officiel et
figureront dans l'analyse politique des
scrutins la séance est reprise nous
reprenons la discussion du projet de loi
relatif aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 dans la discussion
des articles nous sommes parvenus à
l'amendement numéro 72 rectifiés au sein
de l'article 7
et nous sommes donc à l'amendement 72
rectifiés monsieur dessus merci madame
la Présidente
chers collègues monsieur le ministre je
suis content de vous retrouver parce
qu'on a commencé à beaucoup débattre sur
l'article 7 et on a besoin de vos
éclairages puisque nous n'avons pas
beaucoup avancé sur un certain nombre de
garanties que nous demandions et nous
l'avons dit pour vous résumer les débats
que cet article comporte un centre de
risques majeur pour la vie privée et les
libertés fondamentales
nous ne souhaitons pas que ces mesures
soient instaurées on va le répéter c'est
pourquoi nous avons proposé la
suppression de cet article néanmoins il
si elle venait quand même à être
introduite il est primordial de les
accompagner de garanties pour mieux
protéger nos libertés fondamentales et
dans cet esprit de concorde nous
estimons indispensables la transparence
et l'accessibilité des algorithmes comme
pré-requis pour le contrôle démocratique
de l'utilisation qui est faite de nos
données de nos actes et libertés il nous
apparaît comme légitime que le code
source de l'algorithme soit accessible à
toutes et tous pour voir la manière dont
celui travail dont celui-ci travaille et
apprend c'est la base de notre travail
de contrôle il est également nécessaire
d'empêcher la vente et la session des
données qui seront traitées par ces
algorithmes les pays occidentaux et la
France ne fait pas exception
malheureusement ont une longue tradition
de commerce notamment en termes de
matériel de sécurité avec des régimes
beaucoup moins regardant sur les droits
et libertés et nous ne souhaitons pas
que les données d'apprentissage de ces
algorithmes collectés au moment des Jeux
olympiques mais aussi au moment de la
coupe du monde de rugby puisse être cédé
ou vendus à des acteurs publics ou
privés internationaux c'est une
précision que nous jugeons fondamentale
en termes de garantie universelle des
libertés publiques libre accès des
données et garanties éthiques voilà ce
que nous proposons avec cet amendement
si Monsieur dessus madame la rapporteur
avis de la commission merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues ce sera un avis défavorable
rendre les algorithmes ouverts et
accessibles à tous si on comprend
l'enjeu notamment
à propos de parcours sup on voit bien
qu'en matière de sécurité c'est quand
même compliqué de rendre ouvert et
accessible à tous des algorithmes qui
sont destinés à nous protéger quant à
inscrire la non-session des données
d'apprentissage d'ores et déjà c'est le
cas parce qu'elles seront effacées si
elles n'ont pas donné de résultats et
ensuite elles peuvent être conservées
pendant un mois mais uniquement pour
s'entraîner ça reste sous la maîtrise de
l'État il n'y aura pas de session
possible donc avis défavorable monsieur
le ministre avait du gouvernement
bonsoir madame la Présidente
je ne savais pas que
ce serait inconvenant pour Madame bac
caisse qui je suis sûr a su tenir le
rendu du gouvernement je voudrais
remercier ici non mais en plus
d'excellents argument de Madame la
rapporteur je voudrais évoquer deux
choses si nous rendons libres c'est
consultation d'algorithmes d'abord c'est
une propriété industrielle et c'est un
premier point il faut quand même
souligner qu'il est tout à fait normal
que les entreprises de candidatra si
elle ne peut pas être propriétaire de
son organisation technologique et
deuxièmement surtout argument qui
devrait quand même vous frapper monsieur
le sénateur en tout cas les bicycles si
nous rendons publics les algorithmes à
défendre sécurité les gens qui nous
attaquent les terroristes et ça
évidemment les cyber théoristes on a
qu'à leur donner directement les clés du
coffre et comment attaquer le camion on
dira beaucoup plus vite puisqu'on va pas
rendre public la façon dont les
algorithmes de sécurité servent
évidemment à la protection pour une
finalité particulière que sont les
grands événements et régulièrement les
Jeux Olympiques sur le travail que force
de sécurité à travers ces caméras de
vidéos protection donc évidemment un
avis défavorable merci monsieur le
ministre une demande d'explication de
votre monsieur dessus oui vous avez
monsieur Miss merci pour votre réponse
mais vous n'avez pas répondu sur le la
session des données collectées lors de
ces événements
ensuite vous venez de confirmer une
partie de nos arguments que nous avons
développé que c'est Jo seront l'occasion
pour un certain d'industrie de la
sécurité dans magazine et un centre de
données d'enrichir leurs algorithmes
pour plus tard les revendre y compris à
l'internationales pour des régimes les
moins regardants en termes de de ces de
liberté donc vous venez de confirmer ça
merci Monsieur le Ministre ensuite en
termes de de ce que vous avez sur le
d'ouverture des données je voudrais vous
rappeler que la plupart des données de
l'open source est une garantie de
sécurité y compris sur un internet c'est
par l'Open Source et la collabor la
collaboration des différents
utilisateurs que nous avons renforcé un
centre de sécurité dans notre réseau
internet je pense que ouvrir ses
algorithmes nous permettra à nous en
termes de parlementaire d'avoir
la compréhension suffisante pour voir
quels sont les informations qui sont
collectées c'est important puisque nous
avons un devoir de contrôle et puis ça
permettra aussi d'enrichir ces
algorithmes pour les rendre
effectivement plus efficace
merci Monsieur dessus monsieur le
ministre monsieur je propose qu'on
commence pas le débat en faisant dire à
l'interlocuteur ce qu'il n'a pas dit
donc je n'ai pas dit ce que vous avez
dit vous confondez deux choses si je
peux me permettre les données et les
algorithmes qui sont pas tout à fait la
même chose donc vous avez dit que vous
avez dit que les entreprises pourront
garder ainsi les données les revendre
non c'est pas le cas il y a aucune
session de données on ne garde aucune
donnée elle revendue à personne parce
qu'elles sont détruites et pas
d'utilisation de données donc c'est pour
cela que votre point est totalement
satisfait c'est de ne pas garder son
parvendus et deuxièmement il y a un
processus industriel que sont les
algorithmes voilà et effectivement une
entreprise oui ce sera une entreprise
une entreprise a le droit de garder son
processus industriel après vous dites
c'est revendu et pour notamment des
défunts qui sont pas démocratiques
d'abord je vous remercie de faire la
différence entre les pays démocratiques
et enfin une autre démocratique et la
France deuxièmement si nous ne mettons
pas nous en place ce genre de dispositif
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est pas nos
entreprises qui le font ce seront
d'autres le risque le front les Chinois
les Israéliens mais bien sûr ben c'est
exactement la même chose que sur les
caméras de vie de protection ils ont
toutes technologies monsieur le sénateur
après la question c'est ce qu'on veut
être un état avec une technologie forte
propriétaire de notre technologie avoir
nos données à nous la façon dont on a
pas industrielle de fonctionner plutôt
que de se faire imposer des cadres
étrangers comme ceux des Chinois se
disent israéliens ceux des Américains et
d'autres pays encore on préfère que ce
soit une filière française oui avec des
capitaux français que l'État peut
regarder et peut considérer d'ailleurs
que il doit être d'intérêt vitaux que
les services de renseignement peuvent
regarder et ne pas être vendus à la
découpe par exemple oui il faut être
fier des grandes entreprises françaises
ça évite aujourd'hui si on avait eu la
même résonance sur les moteurs de
recherche nous n'aurions pas sans doute
Google aussi monopolistique et je veux
appliquer vos quêtes écologistes la même
chose sur les panneaux solaires si on
avait plutôt pris la révolution de la
panneaux solaires on n'aurait pas des
panneaux solaires chinois par exemple en
France donc accompagner la législation
mais tout le monde le sait monsieur le
sénateur accompagné la législation pour
dire à nos industriels voilà les
finalités démocratiques dans un état de
droit de sécurité comme les Jeux
Olympiques ça nous évite de nous faire
imposer des solutions dans quelques
années différentes et effectivement ces
solutions différentes on le voit avec un
certain nombre de scandales qui se sont
nés et jamais avec des entreprises
françaises vous l'aurez constaté Pegasus
en est un bon exemple lorsque c'est
développé avec un cadre français et bien
nous pouvons parler aux industriels on
peut gérer en partie leurs actions les
réguler regarder leur capital soyons
fiers des entreprises françaises merci
merci Madame la présente monsieur le
ministre juste un petit point de
précision il est parfaitement possible
de préserver la la l'intégrité
technologique des algorithmes et dans
l'assurer le contrôle en même temps pour
ça il suffit de nommer un tir de
confiance qui assure l'analyse de
l'algorithme et c'est ce qui se passe
par exemple pour le contrôle des
algorithmes des gafams des réseaux
sociaux et la CNIL ne fait pas autrement
donc ce qui serait intéressant ça serait
de mettre en place justement tout ce
régime de contrôle des algorithmes pour
s'assurer ce qui a réellement dedans ce
qui est ce qui est très regrettable
monsieur le ministre c'est que s'agitant
des réseaux sociaux il y a une
obligation de communication par loi de
ces algorithmes et aujourd'hui elle
n'est pas respectée donc nos craintes
sur les algorithmes de la vidéo sont
rigoureusement les mêmes merci Madame la
présence
euh s'il n'y a plus de demandes
d'explication de votre je mets aux voix
le 72 rectifier qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
ce qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le 23
rectifié
monsieur Durand merci madame la
Présidente je disais monsieur le
ministre enfin n'ont pas que Madame
Bacquet ce n'est pas fait du du bon
travail au banc mais notre sujet c'est
la banalisation c'est la banalisation de
technologie et comme ce texte est un peu
sensible que cet article 7 est un peu
sensible il nous paraissait utile que
que le ministre de l'Intérieur puisse
répondre à des questions qui
garantissent qu'on s'engage dans un
dispositif sécurisé s'agissant des
libertés publiques l'amendement 23
rectifié vient apporter une précaution
supplémentaire au stade du développement
des logiciels d'intelligence
artificielle qui seront associées aux
images vidéos le projet de loi prévoit
que ces logiciels peuvent être
développés directement par l'État ou par
un prestataire extérieur qu'il choisit
comme il s'agit de la première
expérimentation du recours à
l'intelligence artificielle avec des
enjeux dont on a dit depuis tout à
l'heure qu'ils étaient extrêmement
sensibles nous pensons qu'il faut porter
une attention particulière à la
prévention des conflits d'intérêts c'est
pourquoi nous proposons de renforcer les
exigences auxquelles le développement du
traitement doit répondre si un
fournisseur externe est choisi en
prévoyant des garanties d'un partialité
en plus des garanties de compétences et
de continuité d'activités qui sont déjà
prévues par l'article 7 nous avons tenu
compte des observations pertinentes
comme toujours de leur rapporteur pour
que cette garantie d'impartialité se
matérialise par une déclaration des
intérêts détenus à date et au cours des
cinq dernières années
merci Monsieur dura madame la rapporteur
avis de la commission madame présidente
ce sera un avis favorable car nous
pensons après des échanges que nous
avons eu notamment en commission que
c'est une garantie supplémentaire qui va
dans le sens du juste équilibre merci
Monsieur le Ministre oui favorable
également peut-être une rédaction qu'il
faudra trouver peut-être à l'Assemblée
ou en CMB s'il y en a une sur les
conflits d'intérêts est-ce que vous
définissez pas ce que serait ces
conflits d'intérêts si je peux me
permettre dans votre amendement mais non
non il évoque les conflits d'intérêts
monsieur durent mais définit pas
exactement lesquels me semble-t-il donc
je pense que voilà avec votre accord et
bon en tout cas nous le prenons enfin en
tout cas c'est un livre favorable du
Gouvernement et on le reliera bien
ensemble si vous le souhaitez monsieur
monsieur Durand comme on a l'habitude de
le faire
monsieur le ministre il explication de
vote de Monsieur dessus oui nous allons
voter cet amendement mais je voulais
remercier ministre d'avoir en quelques
interventions confortées
notre point de vue sur cet article qui
n'est qu'un cavalier législatif destiné
à faire en sorte que nos entreprises
reprennent du départ de marché aux
entreprises chinoises en termes de
sécurité globale merci monsieur le
ministre
si chers collègues monsieur le ministre
de nos débats il peut pas y avoir de
cavalier législatif parce que ce texte
initial du gouvernement voilà je le dis
pour le Conseil constitutionnel
très bien je vais mettre au revoir si
vous le voulez bien le 23 rectifier qui
a reçu deux avis favorables qui est pour
quicontre
45 rectifié c'est Madame Delattre madame
la vice-présidente merci madame la
Présidente c'est un abonnement de ma
collègue Maryse Carrère c'est un
amendement qui prévoit que la décision
du préfet d'autoriser l'utilisation de
traitement algorithmique en matière de
vidéosurveillance soit prise après avis
des assemblées délibérantes locales il
nous semble s'agir d'une mesure de bon
sens pour informer nos territoires des
décisions qui sont prises des concernant
le mécanisme de l'expérimentation est
particulièrement intrusif et comporte
des risques en matière de protection des
données de droit fondamentaux aussi il
ne paraît pas inapproprié d'associer les
collectivités au processus décisionnel
d'autant que s'il l'utilisation du
dispositif à vocation à rester
relativement exceptionnel il ne semble
pas que l'ajout de ce simple avis soit
insurmontable du point de vue de la
procédure merci merci chers collègues
madame la rapporteur merci ma présidente
ce sera un avis défavorable madame la
vice-présidente nous sommes ici au Sénat
toujours très attaché à ce que les
collectivités territoriales soient
associées aux décisions et qui est un
dialogue entre l'État et les
collectivités on l'a vu tout à l'heure
sur l'organisation des manifestations
nous pensons que ce dialogue est
nécessaire mais néanmoins nous pensons
que dans la mise en œuvre de pouvoir de
procédure de sécurité
tels que la vidéoprotection intelligente
ce serait alourdir
inutilement la procédure et que ça
éviterait et ça rendrait difficile leur
déclinaisons opérationnelle sur les
territoires d'autant plus que le les
assemblées délibérantes des
collectivités territoriales n'ont pas de
compétences en matière de sécurité c'est
une compétence du Maire avis défavorable
[Musique]
oui puis je préciserai indépendamment
des excellents même leur rapporteur
madame la sénatrice qu'il y a des
groupements comme RATP SNCF qui ne font
pas partie d'assemblée des libérantes
donc rentrez votre amendement
inacceptable voilà donc
c'est évidemment un avis négatif merci
monsieur le ministre je mets aux voix
l'amendement 45 rectifié qui a reçu deux
avis des favorables qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée le
24 monsieur Durand merci madame la
Présidente il nous paraît utile de
rappeler que l'arrêté préfectorale
autorisant l'emploi du traitement
algorithmique à l'occasion du
manifestation donnée précise le
périmètre tel qu'il est strictement
défini au paragraphe un de l'article 7 à
savoir le lieu accueillant la
manifestation et ses abords ainsi que
les véhicules et emprise de transport
public et les voient les desservants
c'est un moment vis-à assuré la loyauté
des traitements dans un objectif de
transparence à l'égard du public ce qui
est une condition indispensable pour
permettre le déploiement de dispositif
de caméra augmentée dans un climat de
confiance à l'égard des autorités
publiques
si monsieur Durand madame l'a rapporteur
avis de la commission merci madame la
Présidente ce sera un avis favorable
c'est un moment précision utile
monsieur le ministre je mets aux voiles
24 qui a reçu deux avis favorables qui
pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
deux amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 62 monsieur dessus
merci madame la Présidente il est
précisé à l'alinéa 28 du présent article
que dans certains cas le public pourrait
ne pas être informé de l'usage de caméra
dite augmentée qu'est-ce qui pourrait
bien légitimer une telle exception
monsieur le ministre qu'est-ce qui
justifierait que les citoyennes et les
citoyens ne puissent pas avoir accès à
des informations relatives à leur droit
et libertés visiblement nous ne sommes
pas les seuls à trouver que les
situations qui relèveraient de cette
exception manque de clarté la CNIL
elle-même s'interroge sur les hypothèses
dans lesquelles une telle exclusion
s'avérait nécessaire elle recommande
d'ailleurs que les conditions
justifiantes cette exclusion soit
particulièrement limitée or en l'état
aucune précision à ce sujet n'a été
formulée par ce projet de loi laknil
estime dans son rapport sur le projet de
loi que l'information des personnes de
l'usage des caméras augmentées est je
cite un élément essentiel pour assurer
la côté des traitements dans un objectif
de transparence à l'égard du public et
qu'elle est indispensable pour permettre
le déploiement des dispositifs dans un
climat de confiance à l'égard des
autorités publiques au groupe écologiste
nous considérons que l'information du
public est une garantie essentielle de
la protection des droits et libertés des
personnes et notamment du droit à la vie
privée comment faire valoir ses droits
d'opposition d'accès de rectification et
d'effacement de ces données personnelles
si on ne sait même pas que ces données
existent à ce titre nous proposons par
cet amendement la suppression de cette
dispense d'information du public de
l'usage des caméras dite augmenter
merci chers collègues le 25 rectifié
monsieur Durand
ah pardon excusez-moi chers collègues
merci madame la Présidente donc
c'est une discussion commune mais
l'esprit est différent nous on vous
propose de compléter le travail
utile de la commission qui a introduit
une garantie supplémentaire pour assurer
l'information du public sur l'emploi du
traitement des données personnelles
prévues par cet article 7 y compris
lorsque les circonstances l'interdisent
ou que cette information entre en
contradiction avec les objectifs
poursuivis par le traitement donc dans
ces cas la Commission a prévu de
renvoyer à une information générale
organisée par le ministère de
l'Intérieur je fais référence au
paragraphe 2 bis nouveau inséré à
l'article 7 et si nous voulons que
l'information du public soit pleinement
appliquée il convient de prévoir
également dans la décision
d'autorisation d'emploi prise par le
préfet de département ou le préfet de
police à Paris que les motifs de
dispense d'information du public soit
accompagnés un minimum de l'information
générale du public sur du traitement
algorithmique cette information nous
semble essentielle car elle conditionne
le cas échéant la possibilité d'invoquer
le respect du droit de personnes à
l'égard de la bonne application de ces
traitements de données personnelles
augmenter par l'intelligence
artificielle sur le fondement du rgpd et
de la directive police justice merci si
chers collègues avis de la commission
merci d'avoir la présidente alors sur
l'amendement 62 du sénateur dossus ce
sera un avis défavorable pense que
supprimer la possibilité d'exception au
droit de l'information affaiblirait le
dispositif et le rendrait beaucoup moins
opérationnel et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avions quand même en
commission des lois ajouté une garantie
sous la forme d'une information générale
du public sur l'emploi des traitements
algorithmiques organisés par le
ministère de l'Intérieur pour informer
les publics des enjeux concernant cette
vidéo protection intelligente donc ce
sera un avis défavorable sur le 62 sur
le 25 de Monsieur Durin qui renvoie
cette information en général organisée
par le ministère de l'intérieur c'est un
avis favorable
merci madame le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre oui madame la Présidente un
avis défavorable sur le premier
amendement et un avis on va dire réservé
monsieur durabel je vais essayer de vous
expliquer pourquoi je pense qu'il y a
une je crois une petite confusion me
semble-t-il sur pourquoi on informe les
citoyens selon la volonté de la CNIL et
de la volonté du législateur qui sont
vidéo protégés aux vidéos surveillées le
terme que vous souhaitez on a eu ce
débat pendant la sécurité globale sur
d'autres sujets que les caméras de
vidéoprotection c'est effectivement
comme vous l'avez très bien dit pour
pouvoir être informé consulter les
données personnelles qui nous concernent
et puis évidemment si on le souhaite
faire effacer ces données ce n'est pas
pour être empêché d'abord d'être filmé
bien évidemment chacun le comprend mais
l'intelligence artificielle appliquée
aux caméras de vidéoprotection appliquer
aux captation d'images ne vise pas à
donner des éléments supplémentaires de
surveillance des individus mais des
situations que pourra faire très
concrètement cette caméra dite
intelligence d'intelligence artificielle
elle pourra regarder quelle est
l'événement que nous souhaitons
retrouver ou la situation que ce sont
retrouvés le comportement que ce sont
retrouvés à rassemblement extrêmement
intempestif
casse d'abribus un sac posé par terre il
ne visera pas à rechercher monsieur
dessus monsieur Darmanin ou monsieur
Durand il ne s'agit donc pas pour la
personne pour le citoyen
individuellement de pouvoir retrouver
des données qui lui sont personnelles
mais l'intelligence ça c'est la caméra
ça veut dire classique qu'il le fait et
qui le fait de manière générale et c'est
pour ça qu'il me semblait que la vie
était réservée pour votre amende et
finalement si j'ose dire il ne mange pas
de temps votre moment c'est pour ça que
je le combat pas plus que ça et sans
doute est-ce la vie positive qui a donné
même la rapporteur mais l'information
générale elle est déjà donnée par le
ministère de l'intérieur soit par les
communes lorsqu'il s'agit de caméra ou
l'état pour la préfecture de police
évidemment de caméra déjà installées
chacun doit installer des panneaux
publier dans le journal municipal la
présence de ces caméras y compris mobile
et tout autre type d'information on a eu
cette discussion pour les aéronefs et
pour d'autres situations comme les
drones dans la loi sécurité globale mais
en aucun cas
l'intelligence artificielle rajoute quoi
que ce soit puisque il ne peut pas y
avoir il ne peut pas y avoir de
captation
sans caméra donc cette information est
déjà donné par la loi et l'intelligence
artificielle vise à retrouver des
situations si tu étais extrêmement
différent si vous avions proposé la
reconnaissance faciale qui là parle de
sujet individuel et donc évidemment
l'information autour des données
individuelles retrouvées par ce moyen
nouveau même dans un moyen de captation
ancien aurait sans doute eu son sens de
discussion donc vraiment je pense qu'il
faut bien comprendre pour ceux nous
écoute qui ne s'agit pas dans
l'intelligence artificielle de continuer
à regarder des données personnelles ce
n'est pas ce que feront ces
caméras
c'est des situations mais comme chacun a
dû le voir sans doute dans des
documentaires dans des films ou dans des
reportages ou dans les auditions vous
avez pu faire et c'est situation sont
extrêmement importantes imaginons que
nous ayons à gérer une alerte à la bombe
pour savoir si elle est sérieuse pas
sérieuse qui a déposé le sac dans
quelles conditions il a déposé un sac
est-ce que cette situation de dépose sac
c'est un oubli ou c'est quelqu'un qui le
fait de manière volontaire ça fait
gagner énormément de temps au service de
police qui l'a déposé en tant que tel ou
les personnes autour d'elle ne sont pas
concernés par les algorithmes et par la
finalité que nous demandons législateur
je constate d'ailleurs monsieur dessus
que et la vie de la CNIL et la vie du
Conseil d'État sur un texte aussi
complexe ont été sans réserve sur cette
situation et les débats qu'on a eu
précédemment et notamment sur la lot
mise sur les questions d'image on est
tous été validés vous l'aurez constaté
par une décision du Conseil
constitutionnel dont je me réjouis donc
je veux vraiment ici dire et je salue le
rapporterai Hervé qui a notamment évoqué
ces sujets de données personnelles je
vais aussi dire encore une fois que la
Haute Assemblée rejetée la maman de
Monsieur dessus pour confusion si je
vous parle le permettez et voilà la
maman de ce Durin sans doute est
superfétatoire mais je veux bien donner
un avis neutre c'est à dire réservé pour
l'adoption
c'est une sagesse monsieur le ministre
un avis défavorable
sagesse neutre bon bah écoutez nous
innovons aujourd'hui mais bon alors je
mets au bois ah pardon monsieur dessus
pour explication de vote et Madame Ribet
merci la présidente là on constate qu'on
est en train de reculer sur sur un
centre de droit
lié à nos données à nos comportements
vous venez de le dire ces caméras enfin
ses caméras elles existent elles sont
déjà là on va aller on va leur ajouter
un système qui va permettre de faire la
différence entre différents
comportements différentes situations
qu'est-ce qui nous fait basculer dans
une société de surveillance c'est qu'un
comporte un individu vous moi un autre
va se trouver dans une situation sans
savoir ce que la caméra va chercher à
contrôler dans son comportement vous
l'avez cité un oubli de sac alors vous
vous êtes rattrapé en disant que ce sera
pas une donnée personnelle mais que ça
peut faciliter quand même d'identifier
la personne qui l'a oublié donc on est
déjà en train de reculer un peu
là-dessus bien sûr que si on est en
train déjà reculer sur quels sont les
comportements acceptés quelles sont les
commencements non acceptés qui
définissent ça effectivement là on le
sait pas ça sera défini dans les
algorithmes que vous n'avez pas voulu
ouvrir donc on est en train de reculer
sur un certain nombre de de droits et
liberté et de la façon dont on peut nous
individus protester contre la collecte
d'assentes de données ensuite monsieur
mini je vous trouve extrêmement
rigoureux sur le la question des droits
et libertés vous l'aviez été le 22
octobre devant nous quand vous aviez
présenté le dispositif de sécurité vous
aviez dit le ministère de l'Intérieur
n'utilisera pas de dispositifs
illégaux qui n'ont pas été réaliser mais
par contre un certain nombre de
collectivités les utilisent déjà ce sont
vos mots là-dessus vous n'aviez pas
répondu ensuite à savoir quelles sont
les collectivités qui utilisent tout ça
quelle est l'action du ministère
intérieur pour lutter contre l'usage
abusif de ces technologies on a déjà pu
voir un centre de marché public passé
pour des technologies qui ne sont pas
encore légalisées et donc j'aimerais
bien avoir réponse aussi là-dessus vous
qui êtes si respectueux du droit merci
simplement pour dire que cet amendement
que que nous proposons et qui a été qui
a un avis favorable de leur rapporteur
c'est pas quelque chose qui qui est
anodin non plus c'est à dire que c'est
il s'agit pas d'une information
individualisée mais il s'agit de lier la
décision à l'information c'est tout et
donc je pense que ça permet plus de
transparence ça permet d'être plus clair
alors vous avez dit ça mange pas de pain
je crois que non en tout cas mais en
tout cas ça ça fixe ça fixe les choses
et ça officialise cette dimension de
l'information du public
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
je veux pas laisser monsieur dessus mais
très rapidement faire croire que Missa
intérieur connaîtrait des situations
illégales interviendraient pas
non mais je suis respectueux je suis
surtout respectueux la Constitution
monsieur sénateur et en tant que
représentant des collectivités locales
vous seriez très Sourcieux que l'article
72 de la Constitution soit respecté par
le ministre de l'intérieur c'est à dire
que ceux ils ont une compétence propre
ne vous en déplaise des communes que de
gérer la sécurité de leurs concitoyens
en ce qui concerne la solubilité
publique la tranquillité publique et les
caméras de vidéoprotection et je pense
qu'à un certain nombre d'élus
écologistes qui serait bien inspiré
d'appliquer les règles de la République
législateur l'aura accordé mais c'est un
autre débat c'est un autre débat on
connaît quelques quelques collectivités
locales qui ont font eux-mêmes
revendications d'ailleurs on voit que
c'est souvent là où la délinquance est
parfois la plus importante on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler si vous le
souhaitez mais c'est un autre c'est un
autre débat il appartient justement il
appartient justement au tiers de
confiance évoqué par votre collègue
communiste que de faire ses contrôles et
je sais que la CNIL y est
particulièrement attentif donc ce n'est
pas au ministère de l'Intérieur que de
fait apporter une tutelle ça n'existe
plus depuis 1981 ça n'existe plus 1980
donc il faut être respectueux de la
Constitution et l'héritage mitterrandien
alors Monsieur Durin vous avez la parole
oui une explication de vote non pas pour
allonger les débats mais pour préciser
un point de vue politique très très cher
à notre groupe au coeur de ce débat
l'argument de notre collègue dessus
s'entend parfaitement on comprend les
réserves que son groupe peut avoir d'où
d'ailleurs des émotions préalables
nous considérons pour ce qui nous
concerne qu'il existe un risque
deux développements rampants à bas bruit
d'un certain nombre de technologies et
quand nous proposons qu'on puisse en
tant que législateur s'intéresser à ces
sujets fixer un cadre c'est pas pour
autoriser ces technologies c'est
précisément pour dire dans quelles
conditions alors même qu'elle s'invite
partout dans nos vies personnelles et
collectives à quelles conditions on peut
les utiliser et pour avoir travaillé ça
a été rappelé plusieurs fois dans la
journée avec Arnaud de belnay et Marc
Philippe daubrais sur la reconnaissance
faciale on voit bien qu'en plus qu'il y
a une porosité des usages c'est à dire
que les citoyens consommateurs
autorisent dans leur comportement
individuel comportement personnel des
choses qu'il réfutent en tant que
citoyen vis-à-vis de l'État et du coup
il faut quand même résoudre ces tensions
donc quand on propose de légiférer de
poser un cadre de définir de ligne rouge
de temps en temps d'autoriser des
expérimentations et c'est la démarche
que notre groupe
dans l'espèce s'agissant de la vidéo
surveillance intelligente c'est pas par
plaisir de permettre tout et n'importe
quoi c'est au contraire pour que le
cadre dans lequel ces technologies sont
développées soient respectueux des
libertés voilà donc c'est vraiment
l'esprit qui nous anime et d'où les
amendements que nous avons déposé pour
que l'information soit claire que les
périmètres soient fixés que les durées
soient limitées que les durées de
conservation soient elles-mêmes limitée
et qu'on puisse avancer ensemble dans la
confiance vers l'usage de cette
technologie merci chers collègues il n'y
a plus de demande de parole je vais donc
mettre aux voix tout d'abord
l'amendement 62 qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté et le
25 rectifié qui a reçu un avis favorable
de la commission et une sagesse
neutre du gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre il est adopté
nous passons à l'amendement 26 monsieur
du Rhin
alors on va connecter beaucoup de
données des données qui sont utiles
d'autres qui ne sont pas ce que nous
souhaitons au travers de cet amendement
c'est de préciser expressément que les
données qui ne sont qui sont considérées
comme non pertinentes non adéquates et
non représentative puisse être
immédiatement supprimés sans attendre
l'expiration du délai autorisé en
commission madame le rapporteur nous a
fait observer que cette mesure est
satisfaite mais il nous semble qu'elle
apparaît pas clairement dans le
dispositif de l'articles 7 qui au moment
où nous parlons est encore au stade de
l'expérimentation s'agissant d'adopter
pour la première fois un dispositif
inédit on l'a vu qui est porteur dans
jeu nouveau pour les droits libertés qui
est sensible le scénar doit veiller à ce
que figure dans la loi les principes
essentiels qui déterminent l'usage des
caméras augmentées c'est une condition
qui pour nous est essentielle
il nous semble qu'elle doit être
explicitement mentionnée le président de
la CNIL d'ailleurs vient de s'exprimer
sur le sujet et à rappeler que le
principe de base de cette application
est conservé le moins longtemps possible
les données si la CNIL veillera à ce que
les données soient supprimées
lorsqu'elles doivent être autant
inscrire dans le corps de la loi
madame le rapporteur avis de la
commission oui merci à la présidente ce
sera un avis défavorable il a été il
était satisfait puisque ces données sont
immédiatement détruites dès lors que
elle elle devrait pas exister pardon
donc on voit pas l'intérêt de le
rajouter dans le texte
je mets l'amendement 26 qui a reçu deux
avis défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté le 27
monsieur Redon Sarrasi la Présidente
nous souhaitons lever une ambiguïté qui
existe dans le texte entre deux notions
qui peuvent converger mais qui ne se
confondent pas la pluridisciplinarité et
l'indépendance c'est une bonne chose de
prévoir que plusieurs spécialistes
s'associent pour procéder à l'évaluation
des caméras augmentées chacun
travaillant dans son champ d'application
ou sa discipline avec la méthodologie
qui lui est propre nous sommes tout à
fait favorables à cette optimisation des
approches pour tirer les meilleures
conclusions de l'expérimentation
cependant prévoir la meilleure
communication possible entre les savoirs
ne garantit pas l'indépendance du
rapport final c'est la raison pour
laquelle conformément à la
recommandation de la CNIL nous
souhaitons préciser que l'évaluation de
l'expérimentation soit conduite en
association avec des experts
indépendants
merci chers collègues madame la
rapporteur
ce sera madame la Présidente un avis
défavorable nous pensons effectivement
que c'est déjà prévu que ce soit des
personnes alitées au caractère
pluridisciplinaire qui a qui fasse
l'évaluation pardon de l'expérimentation
nous avons vu que et déjà eu des
échanges sur le fait que cette
expérimentation elle allait conduire sur
une véritable évaluation qui permettra
d'éclairer législateur pour savoir s'il
faut pérenniser ou non ce système de
vidéoprotection et que nombre de
garanties ont été mises et introduites
que ce soit un texte original ou que ce
soit par la commission des lois pour que
cette évaluation soit faite de manière
la plus indépendante possible merci
monsieur Premier ministre
je mets au voile l'amendement 27 qui a
reçu deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui contre
il n'est pas adopté j'ai été saisie
d'une demande de scrutin ah pardon
monsieur dessus pour une explication de
vote sur l'article 7 si c'est possible
merci merci Madame nous ne considérons
pas que les nos libertés publiques
soient sujets à expérimentation y
compris borné dans le temps nous
considérons que cet article n'a rien à
faire dans ce projet de loi n'en
déplaise à monsieur le ministre nous
pensons qu'il est lié plus qu'il fait
plutôt lieu de forme d'opportunisme
sécurité à destiné à maquer à masquer un
centre de défaillance que le ministre a
connu lors de de du fiasco du Stade de
France et donc nous allons nous opposer
à cet article aucune garantie que nous
avons proposé n'ont été acceptés et donc
nous allons basculer via cet article
dans une un nouveau régime de
surveillance donc nous allons voter
contre
merci chers collègues
plus de demandes d'intervention j'ai été
saisie d'une demande de scrutin public
par les groupes écologistes solidarité
et territoire et groupe républicains sur
l'article 7 il va être procédé au
scrutin publique dans les conditions
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement
mais non j'avais pas vu
le scrutin est ouvert
sonne le demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
résultat sur ce scrutin nombre de
votants 343 exprimer 270 pour
243 contre 27 l'article est adopté